do you see these people here
oh we know they're at the back
um looking don't see any of these people
to you Mike
she Kellyanne yes
that's it see bugs
no I'm uh
no culture
what do you think he's avoiding the
coronavirus hotspot over there with the
rest of the prize yes
thank you let's go
I'm just saying that extra loudly that
we hope everyone says their name
not sure if we got it right or not
do your glasses fog
then I can't see where I'm going oh it's
debilitating it's really nothing
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States and mrs. Trump
like
well thank you very much it's an honor
to be with everybody and very
importantly we're at the White House and
there's no place like the White House
and for those of you that this is the
first time I know I know exactly what
you're thinking because I was here first
time it was still something I never
forget so it's great to have you and our
first lady and I are pleased to welcome
everybody to this wonderful place and
discuss the vital importance of safety
and reopening America's schools we want
to reopen the schools everybody wants it
the moms want it the dads want it the
kids want it it's time to do it you know
our mortality rate is right now at a
level that people don't talk about but
it's down tenfold tenfold so you look at
deaths are way down from this horrible
China virus and it's a disgrace that it
happened shouldn't have happened but it
did and the economy is coming back and
it's coming back strongly jobs are
setting records for two months ago they
set the record and then again almost
five million new jobs last month which
is a record and it broke our last record
of a month before so the numbers are
happening much faster than anybody
anticipated the stock market Nasdaq just
hit another record today and the markets
generally are just really a very small
amount below where they were at the
height of of the market when we first
had to do this about four and a half
five months ago and it's incredible
what's happened when you look at
education my administration has approved
thirteen billion dollars for state and
local education we've approved over six
billion dollars to support colleges and
another six billion dollars in emergency
grants to students very importantly we
waive standardized testing requirements
deferred federal student loan and
interest payments so you take a look at
the student loan program we've waived
student loan and interest
payments and that is something that
people haven't been hearing about and
nobody talks about it but it's a big
deal we pioneered new treatments that
are dramatically improving the health
outcomes vaccines are doing very well
therapeutics are doing very well the
therapeutic research has been incredible
and I think you can have a lot of big
things happening long before the end of
the year or both vaccines and
therapeutics therapeutics that I guess a
little bit of a word we can use for on
the way to a cure but they make you
better I mean to me the therapeutic is
even more important than the vaccine at
this point because people will get
better but the numbers are the testing
numbers are the highest they've ever
been we're almost up to 40 million in
testing and 40 million people which is
unheard of far more than any other
country many times what any other
country is and therefore we have more
cases because we're doing more testing
we have more cases if we did half the
testing would have far fewer cases but
people don't view it that way what what
they have to view though is if you look
at the chart and maybe mike has it but
we looked at it before if you look at
the chart of deaths deaths are way down
so what we want to do is we want to get
our schools open we want to get them
open quickly beautifully in the fall and
the as you know this is a disease it's a
horrible disease but young people do
extraordinarily well I was with the
governor of New Jersey and we were
talking and he said out of and he
mentioned a number which is a very high
number but it's a it's a number
nevertheless thousands of people there
was only one person that died that was
under 18 years old in the state of New
Jersey and that was somebody I guess had
a problem with perhaps diabetes or
something else but one person out of
thousands of people one person died who
was under 18 years old so that's a
pretty amazing stat when you think of it
but I'd like to now just give the mic to
our first lady she's going to say a few
words and then we're going to go with
Mike and Karen pence and then we'll go
around the room a little bit
say a few words and Kelly and you did a
great job this morning thank you really
great so if I might first lady please
thank you good afternoon everyone
the first pillar of my be bast
initiative is children well-being and
taking care of children social emotional
and physical health has never been more
important than during the kovat 19
pandemic the administration has work
around the clock to protect Americans
from the coronavirus but many challenges
for children and families can be just as
invisible as the virus and just as
dangerous when children are out of
school they are missing more than just
time in the classroom they're missing
the laughter of their friends learning
from the teachers and the joy of recess
and play for children with disabilities
without access to technology or host
homes are not a safe place the situation
can be even worse as the start of the
school year gets closer I encourage
parents teachers and school to teach
children about the importance of CDC
guidelines and to implement them when
appropriate children's mental health and
social development must be as much of a
priority as physical health the same is
true for parents many will be forced to
mix stressful choices between caring for
their children and going back to work
and we must address those needs as well
as their own mental health and
well-being as we continue to come
together as Americans to tackle these
challenges I'm honored that you could
all be here today to offer your thoughts
I look forward to working with you to
make sure that Americans children and
families can
be healthy and thriving thank you very
much thank you very much for being
appreciated here and thank you Milani
very much
we just heard Mike was telling me that
governor Santos DeSantis a terrific job
he just announced that the schools will
be open in the fall and we hope that
most schools are going to be open we
don't want people to make political
statements or do it for political
reasons they think it's going to be good
for them politically so they keep the
schools closed no way so we're very much
going to put pressure on governor's and
everybody else to open the schools to
get them open and it's very important
it's very important for our country it's
very important for the well-being of the
student and the parents so we're going
to be putting a lot of pressure on open
your schools in the fall
Mike please well thank you mr. president
and thank you for your leadership I have
seen it day in and day out since you
asked me to lead the White House
coronavirus task force and today is just
one more installment in your commitment
to make sure that our state's and our
families have all the resources they
need to meet this moment our health care
workers are provided for but also
understanding that we've got to reopen
America and reopen America safely but we
convene all of these great leaders from
around the country today mr. president
because you know that to open up America
again we need to open up our schools
again and I want to thank all those
gathered here for their efforts as well
I know I speak on behalf of my wife
Karen when I also want to express our
profound gratitude to the first lady
throughout this pandemic her regard for
families for children
for the the emotional impact that this
has had on every American it's so
admirable and I'd like to invite
everyone to show your appreciation for
our first lady and the
mr. president since the the moment that
we asked the American people to step up
to take efforts to slow the spread and
we in in that 15 days that would become
45 days we encouraged we encouraged
people to refrain from from attending
school if possible to engage in school
from home
whenever it was possible there were two
categories of heroes that emerged a one
was the parents around America who
stepped up as never before and those
that are looking on those that are
represented here should know you're
president the first family your vice
president and our second family are
grateful for the families of this
country and everything you've done to be
the teachers for your children to create
the structure at home where they could
continue to learn even in a challenging
time I also want to say how grateful we
are to the teachers mr. president and
I'm actually sitting next to one who
I've been married to for 35 years as you
know she actually teaches in a local
school in the Washington area a few days
a week and I watched her go in and pack
up crates of art materials the children
could come by and pick up and take home
to continue their learning and so I'd
like to invite everybody to show your
appreciation for the parents and all the
great teachers who have done the work of
continuing to educate our children
throughout this panel
[Applause]
and mr. president and the American
people deserve to know that while we are
seeing rising cases across the Sunbelt
at your direction we're ensuring that
states have the resources the support
the supplies and personnel that are
actually arriving as we speak in states
like Texas and Florida and elsewhere to
relieve health care workers and and your
point I I hope the American people
appreciate the point that you made
yesterday on the national stage and did
so again today that because of what our
health care workers have done because
the innovation and the medicines that
we've been able to make available
literally we have seen fatalities
declined by 90 percent from some of the
worst moments of this pandemic and we're
going to continue work each and every
day to continue to keep those losses low
and steady we're going to save lives as
we reopen our country today mr.
president as you know we spoke to the
nation's governor on the topic of of
this summit and we reflected on the fact
as now 47 governors and the governors of
two territories have announced plans to
reopen schools across America that that
it's important to do so for a variety of
reasons the first lady just spoke of
this is we ought to well be concerned
about children falling behind
academically and there's no substitute
for in classroom learning for in
personal learning and that's been much
discussed at the summit today but as the
American Academy of Pediatrics so well
represented here today recently
reflected there are there are social
costs emotional costs and even physical
costs to our children across this
country that we spoke of the governor's
today it's it's important that we've
reopened our schools as you've directed
for the academic and the intellectual
development of our children but it's
also vitally important that we remember
as dr. McCants Katz told the governor's
today that 7 million American children
suffer from either
mental illness or emotional disturbance
and they they principally receive the
care from health and mental services at
their school and so making sure that
we're we're we're meeting the mental and
emotional needs of our children as well
as making advances academically is what
is what brings us here today the last
thing I'll say to all those gathered
here mr. president is from early on you
have directed our task force and the CDC
to equip families and schools and States
with the resources to operate it was as
early as March 12th at CDC issued its
first guidance for strategies for school
and child care services we issued
decision trees in the middle of May and
just last week I'm pleased to report the
CDC published new guidance for k-12
schools and higher education regarding
the type of testing that is appropriate
and other strategies mr. president we
tweekin bring our schools back and next
week the CDC is going to issue five new
documents how to prepare communities to
return safely decision-making tools for
parents and caregivers symptom screening
cloth face coverings in school settings
guidance and the rest we're going to
continue to flow these resources and
this guidance but as dr. Redfield told
all the nation's governor's today and I
want to acknowledge governor Parsons
leadership and his presence here today
we're truly grateful is that that what
what you've instructed our task force to
do in the CDC to do in this moment is to
say to states around the country into
local communities we're here to help
the CDC has issued guidance but that
guidance is meant to supplement and not
replace state local territorial or
tribal guidance in a word mr. president
you've made it clear to us we don't want
to be the reason any school doesn't real
and so our words are the parents that
are looking on to teachers that are
looking on it
administrators leaders in your community
is that we are ready to work with the
leaders in your school system and in
your state to find a safe and
responsible way to reopen your schools
that's our commitment mr. president
we're continuing to move out on that on
the on the belief that to open up
America again we've got to open up
America's schools and the American
people are taking important steps every
day including this summit today to do
just that and I'm truly grateful for all
of those represented here for being a
part of this important work with that
I'd be happy to recognize mrs. pence for
a few comments Thank You mr. president
thank you Mike Melania I had the
privilege of addressing this group
earlier today and kind of opening up
your summit but I do want to say thank
you to all the teachers I know at my
school everybody quickly learned how to
do online teaching it wasn't something
that our teachers across America were
familiar with and I just applaud them
they have worked so hard and the parents
really are the unsung heroes they really
had to quickly get up to speed and it
was not easy to do
but you know our kids are struggling and
they need their friends and they need
their teachers and they need their
routines this decision to open up the
schools greatly impacts our children it
impacts them academically it impacts
them socially and it impacts them
emotionally so I applaud what you're
doing here today mr. president because
our kids for their mental health and
their academic health they need to be
back in school so thank you well thank
you very much Karen I appreciate it and
I see dr. Redfield over in the audience
and I appreciate it and I know you'd
like to see everybody coming back and
getting back to school in the fall and
I've read everything you've written and
I appreciate that very much doctor
thank you very much appreciate it
governor please look we maybe will go
around the room real quickly we'll go
quickly and we'll get everybody to say a
few words and we'll start with our
governor Thank You mr. president and as
you said when you come here I'm just
honored and humbled to be here sitting
with you the vice president first lady
in the second lady those dreams you
think about someday never match them
imagine them being reality but here we
are and so it's an honor to be here
today let me let me first start off by
just saying thanks to the president the
vice president for what they've done
over the last well since they've been in
office to say the least but over the
last 17 18 weeks they've been on the
phone every week president itself has
been and I don't mean for five minutes
to say hello governors and see you later
in-depth conversation with governor's
across the state the vice president has
been there for almost 17 to 18 weeks I
know that I've been following with them
and the one thing everybody
stressed every day in those phone calls
every week they're trying to do the best
thing they were for this country and for
the everyday people out there and they
were trying to make their full support
to the governor's across this thing and
I just want to thank you for doing that
thank you for for leading as what good
leaders do at times of crisis and I just
want to thank you for that
when the president said he was gonna put
a little pressure on governor's to open
he spills up I will tell you this on a
few phone calls I've had with him he can
put a little pressure on you if he tell
you if he decides to do that I will say
that on that so sometimes so we all need
a little push to get things going what
what the first lady said when she talked
about the kids were so important to me
as a grandparent as a father I said to
her and I think of all the kids that
need to be in school that they're the
ones that have the privilege of going
everyday that's almost common that we go
to school for most of school kids but a
lot of school kids it's a safety blanket
it's a way to get nutrition it's a way
to get counseling it's a way for
somebody to help them when they try out
for help and that's also why getting
schools back open is so important and
then if you want to take that one step
further it's about
making sure people are gonna be
qualified for the workforce of tomorrow
this virus cannot shut our country down
or our states down we have to deal with
it as we would anything else that we
dealt with in this country we have to
move forward an economy and life goes on
and education is part of who we are and
kids need to get back in school parents
need to get more involved in their
schools and be back to involved in
schools as I heard speakers today speak
it's part of as part of who we are it's
how we build a future and I think that's
so important I also want to thank the
second lady for giving me a little
inspiration on a couple of key bills we
signed in Missouri I want to give you a
little credit today we did full
reciprocity in the state of Missouri
yesterday I signed that bill and full
military reciprocity and the second lady
kind of gave me a little inspiration for
that and also my daughter's a school
teacher to do that most of the time we
have a father-daughter relationship
except when it comes to teaching and she
becomes a senior advisor to the governor
when we talk about those issues on that
but again I just want to thank the
president for his support for our state
people appreciate it mr. president I
want you to know that for the first lady
and for where we're headed in this
country because we've went through hard
times before we will continue to get
through hard times and we'll be better
off for it we'll be stronger than ever
so thank you and you won't be changing
the name st. Louis will you no we will
not be doing thank you thank you very
much very important thank you very much
good afternoon mr. president I'm
delighted to join you the first lady the
vice president and the second lady here
today to talk about why it's important
for children to be in school my name is
dr. Sally Goza I'm a pediatrician from
Georgia and I'm president of the
American Academy of Pediatrics children
get much more than an education at
school being away from peers teachers
and school services has lasting effects
for children although this will not be
easy
pediatricians strongly advocate that we
start with the goal of having students
physically present in school this fall
of course returning to school must be
done safely we must take measures to
keep students teachers and staff safe
and with flexibility to adapt as the
to the communities prevalence of kovat
19 the evidence we have so far indicates
that children are less likely to have
symptoms or severe disease resulting
from coronavirus children are less
likely to become infected and they are
less likely to spread infection we know
however that missing school can have
serious consequences for child health
and well-being particularly for students
with disabilities or with special
healthcare needs students who are in
school learn more than reading writing
and arithmetic they also learned social
and emotional skills get healthy meals
and exercise and mental health support
schools help identify and address
learning deficits physical abuse
substance use depression and suicidal
ideation these are all critical reasons
to get such ildren back to school
reopening schools in a way that
maximizes safety learning and the
well-being of children world clearly
require new investments in our schools
we urge you to ensure that schools
receive the resources necessary so that
funding does not stand in the way of
keeping our children safe or present at
school Thank You mr. president we look
forward to working with you and all the
people around this room thank you very
much please Thank You mr. president
Peniche mom from the great state of
Tennessee appreciate the invitation on
behalf of our superintendents our
districts our families our teachers and
our public officials opening up
Tennessee we know that reopening schools
reopens our economy we've got great
examples of where superintendents have
come together and thought through
scheduling to make sure that parents can
get back to work for companies who
support multiple regions we've done an
incredible job with resources 20 plus
toolkits we've opened up free
professional development for teachers
and principals for free statewide and
online tools and I'd also like to just
thank the first lady for her support on
child well-being we had a wonderful
conversation a couple of weeks ago under
the taskforce that we've launched
statewide covering the entire state and
making sure that all of our children
receive a high quality public education
as well as being served in terms of
nutrition transportation etc and I'll
just end by saying as the proud daughter
of a police officer and a teacher I was
raised with safety and high quality
education being
two fundamentals in my home and it's a
great honor to be able to reinforce that
with the schools in Tennessee today
thank you sir thank you well Thank You
mr. president
really thanks to the historic response
that the president has led to this
unprecedented pandemic we have the tools
where we can reopen our workplace we can
reopen our schools and we can reopen
health care we've got the tools when we
think about kids and schools the school
for our children is a center of so much
of their life it is where they get
health care it is where they get mental
health care it is where they can many of
them get nutrition it is it is where
mandatory reporting of child abuse and
sexual abuse happens most often because
of the nature of mandatory reporting
requirements in addition to the social
physical intellectual development that
the kids need from a physical setting in
schools we're at a very different place
now than we were two or three months ago
we have the world's most robust testing
system with close to 40 million tests
having been done we have health system
capacity and personal protective
equipment to enable us to work through
these these outbreaks that we've got
we're advancing on therapeutics as the
president said we now have remedy severe
for hospitalized patients steroids for
lung illness we have convalescent plasma
to treat individuals and just this
morning the president made a major half
billion dollar investment in a
monoclonal antibody that will be a
treatment that could if if a proof
successful and if approved could deliver
hundreds of thousands of doses as early
as late summer early fall we have three
vaccine candidates and just this morning
invested 1.6 billion dollars in a fourth
vaccine candidate that could deliver
hundreds of millions of doses this fall
and into early next year so it's just a
very different circumstance than we ever
had before we know more about this virus
the fatality rate is going down because
we're better at taking care of patients
with with the virus our fatality case a
rate in the United
dates is among the lowest if not the
lowest in the in the developed world
right now and we can reopen our schools
safely with what we know and it's really
simple practices of common sense it's
social distancing it's wearing face
coverings when you're in a setting that
you can't social distance and it's
practicing good personal hygiene the
tools are there to bring our kids back
safely to protect our teachers and our
staff and it's time to do it now thank
you Alex
good luck with all of the therapeutic
center you're getting very close very
close that would be incredible what are
your chances early like in September so
Regeneron which is the one that we
funded at almost half a billion dollars
this morning they are one of the most
advanced we have several very advanced
monoclonal antibody products this
basically takes that convalescent plasma
that recovered patients would donate and
bioengineers that in effectively
unlimited supply that we can do and so
it's a cocktail of multiple antibodies
to give your immune system an immediate
defense and we're studying it both both
were preventing disease as well as
stopping the progression of the disease
so it's really very excited just working
it's basically it's sort of the ABCs of
what we're doing and it seems to be
working well we've got do you have tests
right now that says say it does work
well you've got the initial trial trial
work that Regeneron did and that's why
we're investing in the late stage
development of it but then we have these
other three therapies that thanks to
your leadership we now we have so many
more tools than we had three months ago
in terms of therapeutics so we don't
want anyone to get sick but we have much
better ways to take care of individuals
now than we did three months ago
that's exciting very exciting all right
we'll hold you to it September
you too duck you too doctor please thank
you good afternoon mr. president I'm
Patrick Daly the principal of st.
Vincent DePaul High School in Petaluma
California
we're in Sonoma County I just want to
tell you what an honor this is to be
here this this afternoon
I want to thank you I think the first
lady vice president pence and second
lady for your leadership of our country
really during a very difficult time for
the first lady's love and protection of
children very very important to me and
being a father of four kids three three
daughters and a son it is very important
we plan an opening April 10th that is
our focus I think that we have put a
plan together that is a working document
with all the safety precautions and
policies in place to ensure that st.
Vincent DePaul opens following all the
guidelines that are recommended I think
that as you stated earlier this should
never be political and I think at at
times it has become very political and
many school systems throughout our
United States I think probably
particularly in California so we were
very excited about the possibilities of
the fall and we have three plans one
would be the reopening which we plan
August 10th then a hybrid plan which is
two days on one day off two days back in
and then as I mentioned earlier god
forbid if we had to go back to the
distance learning I just don't think
it's beneficial to boys and girls 14 18
years of age and particularly I really
feel for the parents of elementary
school children who are trying to work
and provide for the families and at the
same time having to stay at home and
teach it's it's very difficult I hear
that a lot from our our own elementary
school but I can't thank you enough for
your leadership of our country and thank
you for this honor well good luck with
your plan and getting them open and
hopefully you could do five days instead
of the two and back and forth I know you
want to be able to do that
so you'll try thank you very much great
job listen good-looking person this is
huh hello mr. president
I'm a student at Saint Vincent High
School my name's Cameron Vaughn and I
personally just want to thank you for
both inviting me and helping to reopen
schools coming on behalf of the students
it really means a lot just to be able to
get back out and it means a lot to our
emotional health and our mental health
just to be out there with our friends
cuz a lot of us don't have that
opportunity and it helped reopen our
schedule so we have something to look
forward to me I'm a person is schedules
I run by a schedule make a schedule for
myself so I just want to thank you very
much for getting us back to that great
job really great thank you very much
we'll get you back okay we'll get you
back soon thank you
Kelly Anne please mr. president mrs.
Trump mr. vice president mrs. pence
thank you very much I listened to
Cameron Vaughn and I'm reminded why
we're here why we're here in this room
today on this very important topic but
why we're here in this administration I
believe a hallmark of the Trump pence
administration has been the success in
looking out for an expanding
opportunities safety and well-being for
the Forgotten child and the Forgotten
child took on a new meaning during this
global pandemic between the first and
third weeks of March of this year just
about 100% of our schoolchildren across
this country of all ages were taken out
of their schools and stuck at home we
saw a few things happen many of which
have been spoken about today but I'll
add one more the digital divide was laid
bare in that so many of our school
students could not access basic digital
assets to allow them to confidently and
competently complete their schoolwork
and to learn and to thrive the schools
are our central nervous system because
our students are the heart and soul of
our nation and so today your message
mr. president mr. vice president that
all children matter and our mission is
to make sure that all children can
safely and securely re-enter their
places of learning very soon this has
also impacted our economy and I have a
soft spot for single moms having been
raised by one there are single moms have
been disproportionately impacted through
their job security their wage-earning
and most of them are not in jobs that
they for which they can telecommute so
we're creating pandemics within this
pandemic the good news is that our
children are at low risk for
transmission even as they are at high
risk for maladies visible and invisible
the great news is that we safely went as
we say for the reopen our schools we are
in keeping with so much of your agenda
mr. president mr. vice president mrs.
Trump and mrs. pence which is to
preserve and expand educational
opportunities to respect the dignity of
all students but to respond to the
individual needs of all those students
by expanding school choice and charters
and educational freedom and opportunity
scholarships allowing them to have more
options as they go through their lives
beginning with the quality and solid
education the president has said if we
as a nation can win two world wars dig
out the Panama Canal put a man on the
moon we certainly ought to be able to
deliver a quality education to each
child and that begins with reopening our
schools and making good on that promise
to each and every one of them thank you
very much thank you thank you very much
Gillian hi mr. president
I'm Jenny Beth Martin with Tea Party
Patriots thank you and thank you mrs.
Trump and mr. vice president and mrs.
pence for having me here today
while I am wit Tea Party Patriots I'm
also a mom and my children are sitting
right over there so thank you for having
having us here today and mr. president
you are right and I hope you will trust
your instincts America is not meant to
be shut down and we have to reopen
schools this fall I've been in touch
with almost a thousand doctors from
around the country I helped dr. Simone
gold spearhead a letter to you signed by
eight
physicians in surgeons who talked about
the side effects of the lockdowns I've
done a second letter with over 150
doctors 240 nurses 330 educators 70
national groups and thousands of parents
and concerned Americans who want to see
schools reopened open reopening schools
is going to stabilize our society I
think it's the number one most important
thing we can do to stabilize our society
from top to bottom whether it is in a
local community just re-establishing
calendars which churches nonprofit
groups traffic patterns people who don't
have children
care about the calendar for for schools
kindergarteners an elementary school
students simply cannot learn looking at
a zoom screen if they could we wouldn't
need schools in the first place we could
just pop them in front of a television
the last place in the world a middle
school student needs to be is online
unsupervised by adults they bully each
other when they're in front of teachers
you can't even imagine what's going on
with social media right now young young
adults and high school students are
losing hope and optimism for the future
and in February they had so much and now
we look we turn on the television and we
can see the destruction that that lack
of hope and optimism is causing
employers have to rebuild their
companies they need employees at a
hundred and ten percent to be able to do
that we did everything we could to
flatten this curve and we have to roll
up our sleeves now and rebuild our
companies but we can't do that when
employees are dividing their time
between taking care of their children
indefinitely for who knows how long and
trying to get their job done I have one
employee who has five children his wife
is a dental hygienist I'm granting him
as much grace as I possibly can which is
easy to do he's a wonderful employee
but I can't even imagine what it would
be like to have five children and all of
a sudden have to home-school them all
and it's not even homeschooling it's
helping them with digital learning
homeschool parents have asked that we're
careful about not conflating the two for
me I'm a single mom now in two thousand
seven eight and nine I went through
financial crisis my then husband's
business failed we lost her house we
lost our cars we lost everything
I cleaned houses to help make ends meet
I've done everything possible to rebuild
I know what those families who are now
unemployed are facing trying to divide
their time between taking care of their
children not knowing if their children
are going to be educated and figuring
out what they're going to do with their
life is the hardest I it's incredibly
difficult and for people who think oh we
can just work at home or where essential
urine and essential employ essential
employee it sends the wrong message
every single person in this country is
essential we are the United States of
America every one of us is essential
every one of us is important and we not
every single family can afford a
computer so that their children can be
online at the same time or Wi-Fi as
Kelly Ann was talking about to be able
to do zoom all at the same time so
families are suffering in the education
is suffering as well and as a single mom
this situation is ripping me in two you
cannot be in two places at once
physically or mentally and I'm doing the
very best I can to take care of my
children their father when they're
living with their father he does a great
job taking care of them but when they're
with me I'm doing everything I can to
take care of them help them prepare for
their senior year of high school make up
prom dealing with whatever else we have
to deal with from the shutdown's
and run a company and work and
it's impossible it's impossible to do
what we need to do so the schools must
be reopened it will stabilize our
country I cannot thank you enough for
doing this today and sending this
message and the doctors who I've been
working with they want to do anything
they can to help calm the fear that is
permeating our country they understand
we have to have a healthy respect for
the virus and we have to be able to live
our lives and though they and I will do
anything we can to help you with that
thank you very much my job looks like
you're doing a good job is your mother
doing a good job she good right you said
the right thing okay great job thank you
very much
mr. president first lady mr. vice
president second lady on behalf of the
great state of Tennessee and governor
bill Lee I want to thank you for all of
the help and resources and support that
you and your administration have
provided us you guys have been
accessible you've been responsible and
that means the world to us in the
state's when we're trying to do our jobs
I'm dr. Lisa pearcy I'm the Commissioner
of the Tennessee Department of Health
I'm also a pediatrician and a mother of
four and I know very clearly that
education and economic prosperity are
key drivers of health we know in
Tennessee that kids have to get back to
school
and parents have to get back to work
it's paramount for our economy and it's
paramount for the health of our nation
and we're doing our part in Tennessee
for that effort and thank you thank you
and say hello to Bill please thank you
doctor um thank you thank you mr.
president first lady vice president
second lady I want to really today was a
really terrific day because it took a
barrack Ins children put him in the
center and said this is not going to be
a unilateral and a you know you two
focal one-dimensional discussion about
kovat 19 but as discussion that
transcended that single moment and
brought in the other issues of mental
health academic health emotional health
and really said that it
important to the whole child to have the
availability of schooling and I think
having that discussion that was
multi-dimensional having teachers here
and students here and the health
commissioners here was and the
Secretary's here was really very helpful
because I think it not only put the
child at the center but also made it
clear about how important these other
issues are that are beyond kovat 19 in
the health and welfare of our children
and so the discussion was terrific and I
think we have a way forward thank you
very much I think I'm on now thank you
for including me so much in today's
event I want to thank you I want to
thank the vice president the first lady
in the second lady for your comments and
for all the concern you've had for the
education of our children I come today
as a parent as an OBGYN physician and is
the managing partner of my practice this
has been a very scary but also a very
enlightening experience to have walked
through it's been quite the challenge
and I will say quite the challenge but
the first thing I want to say is it's so
important to get our children back in
school our higher education students our
high school students and our middle
school students are so embedded in
social media already what they need is
that social interaction with each other
and with adults because without that I
fear what our society is going to look
like the preservation of society is
reliant upon the interaction of these
children day to day face to face with
each other I also saw the anxiety of my
youngest child who's here today with me
may see back and on that side I saw her
anxiety when she came home from college
the anxiety of not knowing how her
education would continue I've been
trying to set up the Xoom meetings and
make it happen
but more importantly not having the
opportunity for those in-person
tutorials or that in personal
relationship with a professor to
complete her courses and I think her
courses did suffer because of it she's a
good student and it wasn't dramatic but
I can only imagine what it was like for
other students my eldest child had a
learning disability to try to bring him
home and do this education online
without that in-person benefit without
the tutors being there present would
have been a disaster to his now very
good career in Richmond and I just fear
for that student especially as we go
back to school I think it's very
important that we also educate these
these kids because they sometimes do
rise above it and feel as though they
don't have the mortality or or the
morbidities or that that problem of
interaction with each other they will
have new family units my daughter will
be in an apartment with three other
girls they will be the new family unit
and it's important that we educate them
for that for when they come home that
they realize that their elders their
grandparents and all are now vulnerable
to and that family unit has changed but
we can do this and we can teach them and
masking they've learned this it's
important but we have to reinforce this
at the college level to keep it ongoing
as a priority and I know that we can do
it the other thing that I as a physician
in a strong believer in is herd immunity
and what I'm not proposing is that we
put all of our students in a big vat and
only the survival of the fittest come
out antibody positive I'm not saying
that I do think it's important to stop
this tremendous isolation that keeps the
virus as the winner we need to get out
we need to have the vaccines to help us
we need to have the interaction that
helps to get that immunity so that we
can protect our vulnerable and we can
protect our elderly and we can protect
those younger folks with comorbidities
because we've got a society that is
immune to the virus and we can put the
virus back in its place and and finally
I just want to again thank you for being
here thank you for hearing me out and
thank you for for putting education of
our children in the utmost and for
putting our economy in that place too
because
as a business owner when I have parents
who have to come late or leave early in
order to educate their children and yet
run a business at the same time as this
lady stated it is incredibly difficult
if not impossible and we want to
maintain their jobs we want to maintain
their work ethic but we also want to
maintain the intelligence of their
children and of our future and so I
thank you again for your interest in
this and for letting us be here thank
you I think it's very important to note
that we've done it right we closed up we
were amazing the way our great citizens
adhered to what we wanted to do and we
saved I think millions of lives now we
want to be open we understand the
disease much better nobody knew what
this was nobody had ever seen it before
there's been nothing like this since
1917 that's more than a hundred years
ago but we saved we saved tens of
thousands of lives hundreds of thousands
of lives and now we're open and we want
to stay open and we will stay open we're
not closing we'll put out the fires as
they come out
I call them embers and fires and
whatever you want to call them but I
think it's very important to note what
we've done we've saved literally
hundreds of thousands of lives I was
going over numbers before with the Vice
President and if you looked at a million
two million two and a half million those
are all reasonable numbers to what we
could have had right now we're at a
number as you know far lower than that
and where would you say we are today
Mike so we're at a hundred and thirty
and we could be it we could be it way
over a million right now and I think it
could have been two and a half or three
million people so but now we're open and
now we understand the vulnerable we
understand who has the biggest problem
with it and we watch that group and that
age group and also people that aren't
feeling so well with respect to in
particular Debra certain diseases
diabetes is bad the heart is bad and we
watch very closely and
we've done it right when you look at
what happened was sweet and I kept
hearing about Sweden with the herd you
know with the pure herd for the the herd
concept of opening up and keeping open
all of a sudden it exploded you look at
what's going on in Brazil and a couple
of other places so we've really done it
right but now it's time to be open it's
time to stay open and we will put out
the fires as they come up but we have to
open our schools it's so important to
open our schools and what you said from
a psychological standpoint with respect
to staying home any longer you can't do
it you can't do it that has great
dangers also so that's where we are
we're not closing we'll never closed you
have certain areas that will have
difficulty and they'll do what they have
to do and that'll be up largely to the
governor's but it's also there in very
strong consultation with us we're
supplying them with tremendous materials
and gowns and masks and anything else
they need and they should be doing it
themselves but we've made a lot of
Governors look very very good we've made
a lot of Governors look very smart that
weren't so smart and some have just done
a good job right from the beginning I
could give you a list I could grade them
I could grade them out from 1 to 50 and
I dare you'd be amazed you might be
surprised at some of them both good and
bad but I thank you very much for your
remarks I think it's very important what
you said I think it's very important
please mr. president first lady mr. vice
president
Karen it's great to be here and to
represent the great state of Indiana as
a president of Ivy Tech Community
College we are Indiana's Community
College so 160,000 students across our
great state and I just maybe want to
remind you as we talked about higher
education the true workforce engine that
community colleges are for our nation
and how important they are and the
students that we serve so let me just
speak a little bit
we don't serve as much the 16 or 18 year
old though we have many traditional
students it's often the single mother
that we heard about 29 30 year-olds and
beyond
coming back part-time and how important
it is that they have access to community
college they're also typically the lower
income our first-generation students are
students of color those that really do
need to have the opportunity for the
American Dream so this has been
incredibly important that we continue to
run and so we have we've been virtual
where we were virtual this summer and as
of Monday vice-president we are doing
completion academies on campus to ensure
that those nurses and welders and all
that need the hands-on and labs courses
that they can be out there joining
America's new jobs that are coming and
being part of a strong economy so we've
appreciated the great support the cares
Act all that's gone on we will operate
we will be face to face we will be
hybrid we will be online we will be
virtual and for our single moms will
even be learn anywhere which means that
they can decide week to week if they can
come on campus or be virtual or be
asynchronous so we know we have to
change to meet the needs but we
appreciate the great support of this
administration and we will continue to
work on behalf of ensuring that this
economy has the workforce and success
that it needs going forward thank you
very much thank you
Thank You mr. president I'm fest Saint
John I'm the Chancellor of the
University of Alabama system which
includes the University of Alabama
UAB UAH and the academic medical center
at UAB it's an honor to be here
appreciate your hosting this when this
pandemic started and we had to send all
of our students home from our
universities many of us were afraid that
this would be the disruption of higher
education for all time that they would
learn that they could learn as well on
their computer from home as they would
on their campuses one thing this has
taught us is we're not worried about
that anymore
our students are yearning to come back
to campus they want to be there they it
has reaffirmed the value of on-campus
instruction at our institutions of
higher learning so last month our Board
of Trustees committed to returning this
fall on all three of our campuses to
in-person instruction realizing that we
could not eliminate all risk with it we
can reduce risk and manage risk in a way
that allows us to go forward so early on
we look to the medical experts at UAB
the researchers and scientists and
doctors there to try to come up with a
plan to make our campuses as safe as
possible and it's safe as any in the
country and we've got a four-part
pillared program that allows us to do
that the first and we believe this is
important is to try to have all of our
students tested before they return to
campus not after they return but before
they return so that those who need
isolation can do that at home and we can
begin the school year second our UAB
folks and our people on all three of our
campuses have developed a symptom
tracking app that's used on the phone it
takes 20 seconds to sign up for in 10
seconds every 2 or 3 days to follow up
on to track symptoms we also have
a program to trace contacts that will
allow us to manage student outbreaks
during the year and then last a sentinel
testing or a sample testing program
throughout throughout the rest of the
school year what this does is not only
we hope allow us to reopen our schools
but to keep them open which is going to
be the hardest the hardest part I want
to thank you and the vice-president for
the assistance that we have received
through these federal programs without
that without those it would have been
very difficult for our medical center to
continue for our campuses to make it
through these difficult times and to
allow us to have testing in place for
our students this fall so we promise to
do our best to provide this essential
service to our students and our citizens
and we greatly appreciate the assistance
just you know thank you very much it's a
great place a great state and you're
right about one thing there's nothing
like the campus if we've learned
anything it's the computer will never
replace the campus they thought it would
for a while didn't they but it didn't
after about two weeks we figured out
that it's much better to have it the
old-fashioned way right that's great
great statement actually thank you thank
you mrs. Thank You mr. president mrs.
Trump mr. vice president and mrs. Spence
I'm a third grade teacher at Blessed
Sacrament Catholic school right here in
Washington I believe mr. vice president
you mentioned some heroes shortly ago I
certainly I agree with you the parents I
couldn't have done this for the past few
months at home without the community of
parents that we have a blessed Sacrement
school and I guess the teachers are
heroes in their own way I believe that
the real heroes here are the students
the students that plugged along that
rose to the occasion in fact one of my
students is here today really stand up
and that's why I'm here they they showed
incredible resilience spirit and all of
the gifts that God has given them I
really believe that the children are our
future as I know that you do and I think
that they are what is truly going to
make America great again so I want them
to be back in school in the fall
thank you we agree thank you mr. Trump
mr. president and first lady vice
president pence and mrs. pence first I
just would like you to know that I
personally pray for you daily all four
of you I cannot imagine the burdens on
your shoulders and I know that it's only
through God that you can handle that and
I'm it's not easy I so so appreciate all
that you've done I am the president of
our school board in the great state of
Ohio and Cincinnati Indian Hill and we
are very actively working to get our
children back in school full-time
altogether as safe as possible
we are fortunately we have a lot of
resources and we're able to do that my
biggest concern and I hope through your
leadership we will not have
over-regulation at the local level that
would keep us from being able to
accomplish that goal my biggest fear is
that we will get everybody back we'll
get into a routine and then because of
regulations and mandates that we would
have to close back down or descent
children home and that is a very big
concern that would be just such a
disruption on top of a disruption so
that is probably my biggest concern I'm
also very happy to hear that University
of Alabama has made the statement to go
back to school I have two college
athletes and we've been waiting all
summer to know what's happening at that
higher education
and it's disruptive they're going into
the into their senior years and
internships were cancelled and it's it's
a scary time it's that's a scary time
anyway on a good day for a young person
so I really hope that our higher
education Institute's will make some
decisions soon and really I'm just
honored to be here appreciate so much
what all of you have done and however we
can help please don't ever hesitate
thank you very much and we'll Alabama be
playing some great football
what's going on with Alabama mr.
president that's not the first time
we've heard that question I can promise
you we are planning to play the season
that the University of Alabama could
understand that that creates great
difficulties and complexities and we're
hoping for that it's important to a lot
of people but we're doing our best on
that one too it's true and say hello to
the coach
great coach yes sir Thank You mr.
president well I don't know about
Alabama but the University of Miami is
gonna be playing yes it's hurricane in
the building I'm Johnny Taylor as you
know and I'm your appointee and I want
to start by saying thank you I remember
being right across the hallway in 2017
when you appointed me to be your advisor
the pret chairman of the president's
Board of Advisors on historically black
colleges and universities HBCUs and
frankly there were people who questioned
whether or not anything would really
come of that and if you were really
committed I remembered visiting with
vice president vice president in the
room just across the hall actually and
you met with 60 almost 70 of our
historically black colleges and
university of presidents they came to
visit and you all welcome to us I
remember meeting with secretary DeVos
early on and there was all of this
commitment to HBCUs and frankly the
naysayers didn't think you would make
good on it the three of you and you did
so let me start by thanking you thanking
you for remaining committed to the
country's 101
historically black colleges and
universities and allowing me to be the
chairman of the board that advises you
all collectively on HBCUs so thank you
listen you've done great by us so far I
mean it says 2017 every year our budgets
have increased but not just financially
but the true support of our institutions
and this today is yet another example of
your advocacy your support of
historically black colleges and
universities that is giving us the safe
space to return safely to to campus we
need to bring our students back because
frankly without these institutions these
great institutions many of our
communities have fragile communities
will suffer in ways that people just
can't quite put their arms around there
are three things that I point out very
quickly first of all online education
the virtual education while it's
wonderful it's not as good as in-person
education in the higher education space
and our students many of them who come
from the most fragile of communities and
many of them didn't get high quality
secondary education when they get to the
post-secondary space they need their
teachers they need to look across they
need to come to office hours they need
the assistance and so we need to
encourage these colleges to open so that
their students can get the best
education and truly experience the
American dream secondly HBCUs are
economic drivers in many of their
communities and many of these
communities they are the largest
employer and you were forged kind enough
to create opportunities owns but you
know when the schools are shut down
there's not much opportunity going on so
we need these schools to be open mr.
vice president mr. president secretary
de Vos so that we we can get the the
surrounding community can go back to
work a lot of those businesses are
struggling if we shut these campuses
down and they've been struggling for a
significant period of time so it's also
just smart business small businesses
need this and then finally the entire
country right now is engaged in a
discussion around you know racial
tension and the need for diversity and
corporate America in particular wants us
to do something about it
well HBCUs
play an outsize role in a song and
helping solve for that problem
historically we've created the over
disproportionately black leaders
teachers doctors lawyers judges etc far
more than the 101 school should be
punching they're actually punching above
their weight and therefore if we're
going to commit long-term to addressing
the racial inequities and and issues of
discrimination in the in our country
HBCUs have to be a part of that and you
do that by getting these kids and these
faculty members and these administrators
back to work so on behalf of the
country's 101 HBCUs as an American as a
father of a ten year old little girl
thank you for the commitment to get our
schools back and our children back
safely so that they can learn and as I
said experience the American dream thank
you thank you Jenny and you're doing a
great job the only thing is I don't
think people know how much we've done
for historically black colleges and
universities nobody knows that we've
done more than any Administration in
history and nobody knows that but maybe
they'll find out eventually you know
they'll find out but thank you very much
appreciate it
please Brad Weller from Shippensburg
Pennsylvania seventh grade science
teachers thank you very much president
for being here and doing all this first
lady mr. pence and I really really want
to thank Karen pence for stealing all of
my information I had written down this
morning and then she did it again after
I wrote the news stuff down just here
this afternoon
so appreciate it no I'm gonna keep this
short and sweet we're ready to go back
we literally are ready to go back I know
our students I know I have three kids at
home they want to go back it's it's it's
time it's time just like your economy
which is the greatest economy ever in
the history of the world I appreciate
that
you had to slow it down the momentum was
gone we did the same thing to our
students last year their momentum was I
mean they were roll and they were
well-oiled machine and then all of a
sudden just you had to throw it and you
had to throw it in park if we just have
to change
gears a little bit this year you know
that's one thing we can do but to throw
it in park again
I don't I don't like that option thank
you you're right
thank you very much Brooke Thank You mr.
president I'm Brooke Rollins the
president's domestic policy chief and
and while I sit here and listen to
everyone I'm struck I don't know that
the world understands but I think it's
so important we have a president who was
arguably one of the most successful
businessman in the history of our
country the first lady who has spent her
time and her talent her extraordinary
skill on focusing on the well-being of
children we have a vice president who
was one of the most successful governors
in the history of our country and we
have a second lady who has a career and
is focused on being a teacher and an
educator this is the dream team I don't
know that there will ever be another
leadership team like the four of you to
lead this country back to even greater
heights than it was ever before in March
of this year 75 million students lives
and their families lives were upended
when they were sent home 75 million plus
families just a couple of months later
here we are in the East Room of the
White House with some of the country's
greatest educators leaders teachers HBCU
leaders coming together to figure out
how to get these schools reopened how to
do it in a safe way and how to do it or
we put children first the good news I'm
so glad that the doctor goes us here
from the American pediatric society
Association because we are now
understanding that that I think an
analysis of forty five studies recently
showed that the preponderance of
evidence indicates that children's or
children are less likely to be
symptomatic have the severe disease or
be really susceptible in transmitted
kovat 19 and for the week ending June
27th school-age children accounted for
only 1.3 percent of kovat 19 related
hospitalizations the evidence is showing
that it really is time for these kids to
get back to school but it really is
about the mental health the well-being
and the emotional well-being of these
kids but also focusing on as this press
this is the last thing I'll say The
Forgotten Americans the vulnerable
Americans who are most susceptible to
the ravages of what happens when we
don't get kids back to school and we
don't get kids and lives back to normal
as the mother of a fifth grader seventh
grader eighth grader and tenth grader
there is no doubt in my mind
representing all the moms in this
country that we'd really love for our
kids to get back to school but it's
about so much more than that it's about
the well-being and safety and economic
prosperity of this country and having
this dream team along with Callahan and
secretary DeVos secretary azar and our
teams here this country needs to know
that we are fighting every single day
for every American and to ensure that we
can reopen safely and make sure that
it's done in the proper way so thank you
mr. president
Thank You Brooke thank you very much
please mr. president mrs. Cronk mr. vice
president
mrs. pence it's an honor to be here
representing Forsyth County Schools and
Forsyth County Georgia we're about 30
miles north of Atlanta soar 52,000
students in our school system we're
ready to go
we're gonna open our doors on August 6
we've been planning and preparing all
summer we will have guidelines in place
I'm really proud of our teachers and our
students how well they perform last
spring but as everyone has said this
morning this afternoon our students need
to be back in school and we will be
prepared on August 6 I will assure you
of that that's great that's great thank
you very much
Thank You mr. president mrs. Trump mr.
vice president
mrs. pence mr. president thank you for
your bold leadership and for convening
us here today for this vital
conversation it's clear our nation's
schools must fully reopen and fully
operate this school year anything short
of that Rob's students not to mention
taxpayers of their futures and their
futures represent our nation's future so
it's not a question of if it's just a
question of how we had a good discussion
today on how to ensure schools reopen
and education continues in ways that
keep students and teachers healthy and
safe under the president's strong
leadership our economy is roaring back
our schools must do the same this is the
moment for American educators to rise to
meet the needs of every student
students can't afford to fall further
behind even before the virus too many
were trapped in schools that don't meet
their needs so this is the time to
reopen schools to rethink school to be
more nimble more agile more responsive
to students needs in a 21st century
changing world this moment demands
actions not excuse making or
fear-mongering we've done whatever it
takes before and as Kellyanne said
earlier and as you've often said mr.
president we've dug out the Panama Canal
we've won world wars we've reduced the
Berlin Wall to rubble and thanks to you
we've defeated Isis with grit
determination and grace we can do what's
right for all students and ensure they
are back in school thank you thank you
very much we appreciate it
very nice please good afternoon thank
you mr. president first lady Trump vice
president Pence and second lady pence
it's an honor to be here my name is
Nichole Washington I am a trustee at the
Florida Agricultural Mechanical
University in Tallahassee as well as
miami-dade College in Miami Florida as
you both well know our stoop our schools
didn't close in many ways the pandemic
accelerated trajectory that we were
already on to use technology to expand
services and programs to students it's
not been easy I actually had the
pleasure of teaching a class in a
synchronous class this summer at the
University of Miami and I applaud all of
the faculty and the staff who have had
to pivot on a dime and provide these
services to students Florida A&M is
actually going to to open we're going to
invite all of our students back in the
fall the board made this decision based
on a McKinsey survey survey that found
that only a third of our students would
likely stay if we chose to remain remote
online further for the fall students
would choose either better online
options or options closer to home or
toward more cost-effective measures and
so we do want to - we are going to
reopen we do want to reopen I think
there are obviously
concerns either way but if we remain
virtual we have enrollment concerns
student engagement concerns as well as
budgetary concerns and then if we open
we have to be very cognizant and
vigilant about health and safety
liability concerns as well as the costs
associated with reopening we're very
thankful for the cares Act additional
allocation for testing tracing
sanitation that that will be a recurring
cost going forward what I would like to
close on is the pandemic dispelled the
myth that higher education can change on
a dime our institutions are printing PPE
we've expanded student services
virtually online that we didn't think we
could do our students are creating apps
and I hope that we encourage those
innovations to continue after after we
return to the new normal and provide
high quality just-in-time services to
accommodate our students preferences and
their schedules so thank you thank you
very much thank you
please Thank You mr. president first
lady mr. vice president and mrs. pence
for the honor of being here today
my name is Delaney McDonald and I'm the
student trustee at Middle Tennessee
State University
I was actually homeschooled all my life
by choice not because of a pandemic so I
really understand what people have been
going through and I was honored to
receive the Buchanan fellowship at MTSU
which that is the highest academic
scholarship given to incoming freshmen I
was heavily involved on campus I
actually served as a student body
president as well so I know the extreme
importance that the campus environment
has on student success my fellow
students across the nation have lost a
lot this year and it is important to all
of us to safely return to campus this
fall my university has done an
exceptional job of updating the students
of reassuring them that they are
tirelessly working for our safe return
to campus and I'm honored to be here
today
in this discussion and I'm really
excited to take back what I learned to
my fellow student body thank you very
much good afternoon mr. president first
lady mr. vice president
second lady I will brag on her she is an
MTSU student I'm the president of Middle
Tennessee State University we track we
attract the best and the brightest not
only in the state of Tennessee but from
around the United States I like all the
participants here this afternoon I'm
honored to be a part of this very
important conversation regarding the
reopening of schools colleges and
universities for the past 20 years I
have served as president of this great
institution we are 37 miles southeast of
Nashville a university was established
at 1911 yes and we were are right now
one of the largest undergraduate
university in the state of Tennessee
we've grown tremendously over the years
and we are proud to be one of the
Princeton Review 2020 300 plus best
university in the United States of
America we don't some incredible things
there at that University we have 22,000
students a very diverse student body 38
percent of our freshman class
first-generation and we are proud of
that 40 percent are low-income average a
CT score is one of the highest in the
state of Tennessee we are major
comprehensive University and each year
for the state of Tennessee we produce
more degrees that any University 5,000
degrees each year MTSU produces for the
state now somehow highlights of our
decision to reopen we stepped out we
were the very first University in the
state of Tennessee to announce
we are gonna reopen for the fall in
person classes but in reality is the
president we never closed because of the
nature of our student population many of
our students had nowhere to go in March
when a lot of schools closed down and so
we kept our residence halls open we kept
our cafeteria and we provided the same
service obviously taking consideration
the virus and so we feel that we've we
have the experience of actually
operating a university in a pandemic we
regard the health and the safety of our
students and our employees as priorities
and it was really interesting as we were
making this decision we have a very
active parents Facebook page sometimes
too active we have a very active student
body Facebook pages so we surveyed them
we surveyed our parents and our students
and we asked them their feelings about
returning and what their return the vast
majority of both our parents and our
students from that survey indicated to
us that they would want our University
to be opened so my executive team that
made these decisions including the
doctor of our health center we decided
that we were going to put together a
plan that would make our parents and our
students confidence we can't guarantee
anything was regardless of a virus but
we felt if we communicate with them and
put a mitigation plan together and I
have two of my colleagues here from the
state of Tennessee you've met already
and my university had a meeting was last
week commissioner
she brought her staff down we have put
together a very strong mitigation plan
that is it testing contact tracing and
isolation and
one team if needed for our students I
want to just give a brief overview of
how the cares money really helped our
university was the president as we look
at pivoting from in person to online and
remote we always had a strong technology
operation but we needed to build a
stronger one that would provide the
quality education so we invested six
point nine million dollars three point
four of the six point nine came from the
cares Act and this investment allowed us
to purchase the newest instructional
technology to facilitate teaching and
learning at the university what does
this mean is that regardless of where
student is each every single class at
our university is going to be captured
electronically and it's going to be
archived and students would be able to
access those lectures at anytime
anywhere which means if a student gets
sick or they have to attend to a sick
parent and they can't make it to class
or they they are not going to be
disadvantaged as a result of this
technology and so we believe that is in
the best interest of our students to
open up to provide that top quality
education we feel that for our students
our university provided 459 lat tops
free laptops for our students 673
Internet hotspots free for faculty 101
laptops 235 Internet hotspots and so I
close with us that we must understand
the demographics we must understand our
community and indeed we must understand
some of the challenge
is that we are going to face in higher
education and because of the
demographics of our student population
we've worked very hard to address the
issue of the desperate and disapper
prett amount of minorities and people of
color and low income that are being
affected by this virus and so we've
partnered with one of the sororities the
AKS and they've put together an
incredible package of information that
will be given out to our students as
they return thank you so much for having
us and we look forward to this
conversation and I learned quite a bit
today thank you sir thank you very much
thank you very much great job - so I
want to thank everybody and I want to
just say get open in the fall where what
you have schools open it's going to be a
much better climate than it is right now
on the right side of things Debra I
think we can say that a lot of work has
been done we understand what we're doing
very very well
again mortality rate the lowest anywhere
in the world and we want to get this
done and we want to get our country
going again economically we're doing
well we want to do well with the
education I see well Harvard announced
that they're closing for the season or
for the year I think it's ridiculous I
think it's an easy way out and I think
they ought to be ashamed of themselves
you want to know the truth but I noticed
that today and probably others are doing
that that's called the easy way out I
don't know if people are helping them I
guess their endowment is plenty big they
don't have any problem with that but
that's not what we want to do because
it's very important to so many of the
parents and instructors said today it's
so important that the children at this
age especially that they're together
that together on campus and that's what
we're striving for and we're going to be
very strong in that we're going to be
very very powerful in that view we want
our schools open in the fall tomorrow
I'm meeting with the President of Mexico
I say that to the media because it's
going to be a quite a meeting
he's a good man is a friend of mine and
we have a great relationship with Mexico
so we'll be meeting tomorrow thank you
all very much thank you thank you very
much congratulations everybody
[Music]